a great benefit great event rather to
benefit a great cause this is miracle
flights and their mission to assist
families and of course we're talking
about delicious food and drinks all to
go to america florida truly amazing
organization based here
the fundraiser going to be tonight at
jaguar land rover there's mary jane
belliesa joining us live it's not too
late to get tickets mary jane take it
away
well john and heather for 35 years
miracle flights has provided the
financial ease for families when it
comes to traveling for medical
appointments and now you can help those
families in need too the community is
invited to a signature cocktail
fundraiser hosted by red rock city
lifestyle magazine and it's the first
one hosted at jaguar land rover the
owner of the magazine is on a mission to
raise support for our local non-profits
and proceeds from this benefit will help
fly out families in need of appointments
for life-changing medical
conditions across the country one woman
says miracle flights was crucial in
helping them fly out to treatment for
her sister who has epilepsy
since i took over as the new publisher i
wanted to use the magazine as a vehicle
to support local non-profits and miracle
flights is my first partner in
generating this awareness to two great
causes really has helped my sister by
giving giving her a path to
have more access and range to those
medical appointments that we couldn't
necessarily travel to
due to gas expenses or mileage
and miracle flights free flights has
really impacted her overall health and
well-being
via brazil will serve unlimited food and
drinks at this event tickets cost thirty
dollars and we do have a link for you on
our website if you'd like to purchase
some at eight newsnow dot com again that
fundraiser will take place here
tonight at 5 30 to 8 30 p.m at jaguar
land rover really benefiting a great
cause here reporting live mary jane
belliesa live local now